las noticias no son para mí
piensen con mucho cuidado de esta frase
quien de aquí sabía los 10 años que
quería estudiar oa qué se iba a dedicar
yo les voy a contar que en mi caso así
fue o por lo menos lo fue hasta hace un
par de años uno de los recuerdos más
vídeos que tengo en mi infancia de los
viajes familiares esto en joyce en el
coche y mi papá empezaba para
entretenerme preguntar cosas de cálculo
mental o cualquier juego que tuviera que
ver con las matemáticas al fin y al cabo
él y yo teníamos un plan yo iba a ser
actuaría igual que yo entré al despacho
familiar iba a crecer lo que él ya había
iniciado
y bueno claro en ese momento yo ni
siquiera sabía que era la actuaria pero
no importaba yo tenía un don para los
números y bueno había que aprovecharlo y
así fue más o menos a los 23 años me
gradué en la universidad uno de los días
más orgullosos de mi vida fue cuando
presenté mi examen profesional y recibí
mi título como actuario luego llegó el
envío y bueno es así que llegó a cambiar
todo claro al principio era como una
forma de aumentar mis conocimientos
personal administración de empresas en
finanzas pero bueno como les digo cambió
todo la maestría desde un principio me
abrió un mundo que yo que me consideraba
muy educada y muy viajada no conocía
convivir con personas tan diferentes a
mismas 24 horas me hizo darme cuenta que
somos parte de algo muchísimo más grande
que somos chiquititos me hizo darme
cuenta que somos que la moneda no tiene
un solo lado
cuántas veces hemos viajado fuera de
mexico y nos llegan a preguntar oye en
méxico qué onda con los burros o qué o
cómo le haces para llegar de un lado a
otro sin que te maten claro sabemos que
estos son estereotipos viejísimos y nos
chocan pero nosotros también los tenemos
me acuerdo también en la maestría que
una de las primeras personas que conocí
fue un amigo jordano y me acuerdo que
siempre traía como una crucecita aquí y
vestía una cruz que raro si es gorda no
necesariamente tiene que ser árabe no
perdón musulmán hasta eso era lo que me
habían enseñado en la escuela y bueno ya
un día me atreví a preguntarle cómo y
por qué traes una cruz
si eres halar y me dijo pues sí o sea
soy árabe soy gorda no pero el 5% de los
jordanos son cristianos y pues yo soy
uno de ellos y también no explicó que
ser árabe y ser un musulmán era una cosa
totalmente diferente pero bueno varias
experiencias similares misión
interesarme muchísimo más en lo que
estaba pasando alrededor del mundo y
hasta en méxico me hicieron que leer me
hicieron querer leer sobre eventos que
aunque yo sabía que estaban pasando no
tenía
ni idea de por qué ni cómo y así fue que
me fui metiendo al tema de las noticias
y me empezaron a gustar tanto que cuando
se me presentó la oportunidad dije uy yo
quiero hacer algo grande con ellas y
bueno pues ya se imaginarán la cara de
mi papá cuando le dije que nuestro plan
de actuarios iba a tener que esperar un
poquito porque se me había presentado un
nuevo camino
y bueno pero bueno esto ya es otra
historia
hablando de historia quién de aquí se
acuerda que estaba haciendo en el verano
de 2014
a mí ese verano nunca se me olvidará
porque este año hubo una guerra y a mí
me tocó vivirla cuando decidí que quería
hacer el servicio social en belén me
costó la vida convencer a mis papás les
dije de todo que el año anterior habían
ido unas amigas que decían que era la
mejor experiencia de su vida o que yo
como internacionalista nunca iba a tener
una mejor oportunidad para conocer medio
oriente en la región del mundo que más
me apasiona en fin lo logré y ese año me
fui a palestina
en el verano de 2014 israel acusó a
palestina de secuestrar a tres
estudiantes palestina le dijo que no los
tenía y yo nada que ver con el tema sin
saber quién tenía la razón quedé ahí
metida en medio del conflicto
me acuerdo perfecto que un día una de
mis compañeras del servicio social que
estaba viviendo con una familia de
palestinos me dijo que la noche anterior
había habido unas manifestaciones medio
violentas cerca de su casa con gas
lacrimógeno y que había sido todo un
caos no una semana después el gas
lacrimógeno se convirtió en bombas
molotov y ahí sí como que ya me asusté
pero una parte de mi cabeza seguía
diciendo como bueno así es esta zona del
mundo no siempre hay tensión se va a
relajar pero no no podía estar más
equivocada y no me cayó el 20 hasta el 8
de julio ese día cayó el primer misil y
yo lo vi y lo sentí como que algo me
empujó para atrás como se ve en las
películas la verdad no sabría explicarlo
muy bien pero fue la vez que más miedo
he tenido en mi vida
ese mismo día
y con toda esta experiencia decidí que
quería dedicarme a algo que tuviera que
ver con las noticias entonces en cuanto
regrese a méxico me gradué de la
licenciatura y entré a trabajar al medio
más importante del país estaba viviendo
el sueño no hacía reportajes de los
temas que más me gustaban y salían al
aire prácticamente todos los días
pero había un pequeño detalle que es que
nadie de mis conocidos se estaba viendo
lo que yo hacía con tanto orgullo me
acuerdo perfecto que un día llegó una de
mis amigas y me dijo como oye tú que
estás como muy metida en estos temas
explícame qué es eso del estado islámico
porque diario veo notas de soy de verdad
no sé qué es y yo como oye acabo de
hacer un reportaje súper orgullosa te lo
voy a pasar o buscarlo para que veas
cómo empezó el grupo terrorista dónde
está hoy te va a quedar todo clarísimo y
ella me dijo no la verdad no no va a ser
así cuéntamelo aquí y ahorita y eso me
pasaba muy seguido yo iba a las pláticas
familiares con amigos y entre las
conversaciones cotidianas acababa
metiendo temas complejos o que no
necesariamente son los más divertidos
como la guerra en sí la y yo mientras
tanto del otro lado del mundo me había
dado cuenta que en mi caso de no saber
sobre ciertas cosas que estaban pasó en
el mundo era muchísimo más común de lo
que creía y que mis amigos y compañeros
no estaban leyendo las noticias no están
informando de nada uno es por falta de
tiempo otros por falta de interés
y mi pasión por las noticias ya era tan
grande que junto con una amiga que luego
pasó a ser mi socia nos propusimos
lograr que nuestra generación fuera la
más informada de todas queríamos
desafiar ese estereotipo de que los
jóvenes de hoy no leen de que lo único
que les interesa son las redes sociales
queríamos hacer el medio para
millennials más grande de latinoamérica
para contarle al mundo sobre la guerra
en yemen sobre la crisis económica en
venezuela sobre los movimientos que hay
para acabar la brecha entre hombres y
mujeres queríamos hacer algo tan grande
que nuestro amigo nunca más pensará que
esta guerra comercial entre china y eeuu
no le afecta a su cartera o que sería
estar informado no es para él y aunque
apenas ahí vamos cada vez nos sentimos
un poquito más cerca hace un año
justamente dejé salir me decidí salirme
de ese medio del que les estaba
platicando ahorita para irme a te lo
cuento un medio que apenas hizo nada
pero que justamente le sonaba a la gente
de mi generación
hoy en vez de tener que explicarle a mis
amigos esos temas complejísimos de los
que les platicaba hace poco ellos leen
las noticias todos los días
opinan me dan su punto de vista nos
debatimos etcétera me he dado cuenta que
esos temas que tal vez yo consideraba
que eran un poco como geeks le interesan
a todo tipo de personas con todo tipo de
perfiles así es lo que pasó es que
después de dos años de trabajo nos dimos
cuenta que nuestra generación si estaba
interesado en saber sobre el mundo que
así como le interesaba la nueva serie de
netflix también le interesaban otro tema
otro tipo de temas políticos sociales
económicos etcétera que si estaban
interesados el único problema es que los
medios tradicionales no están conectando
con ellos hoy hay tanta información que
la gente necesita que alguien le haga un
resumen de las noticias se las cuente
pero que no deje fuera el contexto que
le expliqué porque están pasando las
cosas y como algo que puede estar
pasando en china o en cualquier otro
lado del mundo le puede afectar a esa
persona que está hoy aquí sentada en
mexico y hoy tenemos todo tipo de
lectores desde
es hijo de una empresa importantísima en
mexico hasta un niño de 18 años que ni
siquiera sabe que va a estudiar que es
lo que los une precisamente esta
necesidad de estar informados porque es
horrible estar en una plática familiar y
que todo el mundo empiece a hablar sobre
un tema muy importante como por ejemplo
el nuevo aeropuerto de la ciudad de
mexico el aumento en el precio de la
gasolina y que tú te sientes ahí callado
sin tener nada que opinar porque de
verdad ni siquiera empiezas a entender
cuál es el problema y por la porque la
gente informada aunque sea con lo mínimo
indispensable siempre va a tener mucho
mejores oportunidades que las demás
pongamos un ejemplo a quién crees que le
daría en el próximo ascenso en el
trabajo aquí que siempre te esfuerzas
por hacer lo mejor por tratar de tener
todo perfecto oa tu compañero que además
de eso siempre expone sus puntos de
vista sobre ciertos problemas que están
pasando en méxico o resultan las ideas
de su jefe con argumentos sólidos
las noticias son para todos porque todo
aquel que no conoce su historia está
condenado a repetirla cuántas veces han
escuchado esta frase han pensado alguna
vez realmente qué significan cuántas
veces hemos creído que una cosa como un
genocidio o una guerra civil es algo del
pasado que no tendría por qué suceder
hoy en pleno siglo 21 si estás informado
sabrás que ambas cosas pasan todavía hoy
en el mundo y que es nuestra
responsabilidad tratar de cambiarlas o
por lo menos tratar de evitar que pasen
en nuestros propios países las noticias
nos transforman sin que nos demos cuenta
hacen que estemos mucho más conscientes
de todo lo que nos rodea y que seamos
parte de algo mucho más grande hacen que
antes de tomar una decisión importante
en nuestra vida como comprar una casa
decidir en qué vamos a invertir nuestro
dinero o incluso quién queremos que sea
nuestro próximo gobernante salgamos a
informarnos comprarías todavía la casa
de tus sueños si te dijera que estamos
viviendo en la burbuja inmobiliaria más
grande de los últimos diez años estar
informado hace que salgas a manifestarte
por las causas en las que crees
a pelear por tus derechos
y sabemos que no basta con leer
titulares sabemos que hay que adentrarse
en la noticia entender el porqué y el
cómo porque son precisamente estas dos
partes las que nos transforman las que
hacen que no repitamos los mismos
errores una y otra vez son los que nos
cambian como sociedad
y tú sigues pensando que las noticias no
son para ti